[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition du café
politique sur tv fil 78 revue de presse
de l'actualité de ces quinze derniers
jours en compagnie d'élus du département
et pour m'accompagner au cours de cette
prochaine demi heure aziz françois
n'diaye bonjour vous êtes le porte
parole dans les yvelines du mouvement en
marche j'arrive maximilien bonjour vous
êtes responsable de la section locale du
parti communiste français sur saint cyr
l'école et d'arvida rita abbey dario là
tu vas tu pardon bonjour bonjour vous
êtes conseiller municipal d'opposition
les républicains sur la commune de la
verrière alors on va débuter par à
l'actualité politique forcément la
primaire de la droite et du centre
juste une petite précision
d'introduction nous enregistrons elle
cette émission pendant
l'entre-deux-tours a dès le dimanche 27
novembre koné sera le nom du candidat
pour le parti des républicains mais en
moins vous retenez quoi chacun un peu
ddd des résultats quels sont les
enseignements que vous vous en tirez on
va commencer avec vous peut-être pour
les républicains je pense qu'il faut
retenir que françois fillon a défié tous
les pronostics tous les jugements qui
ont été faits par les médias je pense
qu'il a aussi fédérer puisque je crois
que l'élection des primaires des
républicains et du sens car et l'avenue
plus de 4 millions de français ce qui
est quand même énorme c'est je crois
c'est un record donc ça prouve qu'il a
été deux millions sept pour la primaire
de la gauche en 2011
voilà ça prouve bien que françois fillon
et je pense s'il ya pas qu les
républicains ont tous voté mais aussi
les personnes les sympathisants de
gauche et qui ont choisi peut-être leur
futur président vous êtes un jeune élu
rejet pas préciser votre âge mais 23 ans
et 23 ans quand vous voyez que ça se
joue alors aujourd'hui entre alain juppé
françois fillon vous inspire quoi il ya
un mot il ya un renouveau dans la classe
politique
juppé je pense que
personnellement alain juppé je pense
qu'il a fait son temps puisque ici
termine son mandat s'il est élu
président arrêté dès qu'il termine son
mandat il aura 77 ans il a dit qu'il
ferait qu'un seul mandat sociétés des
banques 77 ans vaut mieux mais voilà
françois fillon je pense qu'il est plus
apte il un programme je pense qu'ils qui
ressemble en tout cas les idées et aussi
qui est dynamique puisque il propose
énormément de mesures pour la formation
l'apprentissage et chez des jeunes donc
je trouve très compétent avec maximilien
oui bon je dirais les deux candidats
c'est un peu les deux faces d'une même
médaille mais ces deux orientations
quand même qui s'est désolé station
passionnante qui sont très comment dire
proche malgré tout et ils ont appliqué
ils appliqueront l'un comme l'autre
une politique libérale qui
ce sera contre les intérêts des salariés
les chômeurs et même de l'économie à
terme puisque on voit ce que ça donne
aujourd'hui et on sait ce que ça donne
d'ailleurs le libéralisme mais nos murs
mais quand on dit que se joue
aujourd'hui le nom du prochain président
que tout serait quasiment jouée avant
même le scrutin du mois de mai mai 2010
est la vraie présidentielle qu'on soit
d'accord avec ça je pense que il ya
encore beaucoup de choses qui peuvent se
jouer sur les mois qui viennent et je
pense notamment du côté de la gauche
aujourd'hui il y a je parle de la gauche
réellement alternative de progrès je
pense qu'il ya une multitude de
candidats et
que nous au parti communiste on souhaite
que ce que dit hier un rassemblement de
ces candidatures de façon à porter haut
et fort
la voix de ce courant politique pour
réellement remettre en cause la marche
de l'économie telle qu'elle va
aujourd'hui parce que la gauche part
divisée très clairement aujourd'hui
enfin tous les noms sont pas encore
connus mais quand on voit melanson d'un
côté la candidature probable du
président hollande voire de manuel valls
s'est pas encore mais ça va se dessiner
dans les prochains jours vous êtes très
divisé on va parler dans marche aussi
qui s'inscrit alors vous allez nous le
dira au centre hors des partis à gauche
on va voir ça dans un instant mais la
gauche est très divisée comment
réconcilier tout le monde alors je pense
que il ya d'une part
le mouvement socialiste qui aujourd'hui
sociale libérale et qui a son propre
calendrier avec ces primaires ou en
effet pas le seul land vont pouvoir
s'inscrire avec montebourg et compagnie
d'autre part
il vient à la gauche
la gauche progressiste
qui en est fait aujourd'hui est divisée
avec la gauche et l'écologie avec une
par une candidature écologiste de 3par
la candidature de mélenchon d'autre part
également la volonté
pour les communistes de porter une
candidature
qui souhaitent être une candidature de
rassemblement
pour justement essayer de fédérer ses
autres candidatures et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
avec ce qui s'est passé dans les
dernières années les batailles contre
les politiques libérales du parti
socialiste une candidature de
rassemblement à gauche du parti
socialiste peut faire un score important
et être au deuxième tour des
présidentielles l'année prochaine aziz
françois n'diaye dont vous êtes le porte
parole dans marché en département des
yvelines ça y est emmanuel macron a
déclaré sa candidature la dernière fois
que j'étais venu en plateau c'était
c'était encore un petit léger suspense
maintenant ça y est il est il est
déclaré
concrètement il va réussir à se faire
une place
il a déjà occupé l'espace mais permet
tout juste de revenir sur la lecture que
je fais
du scrutin des primaires les clichés
n'ont pas choisi leur président et je
pense pas que le vote de dimanche
dernier doit être vue sous cet angle là
je pense plutôt qu'il y avait
un mini référendum sur oui ou non pour
le retour de sarkozy et pour ma part je
l'enverrai la lecture sont abstraites
encore reviennent avec la participation
pour le second tour c'est pour cela je
fais vraiment une lecture différente et
je pense que tout est ouvert pour le
second tour mais je ne pense pas que par
ce vote même massif et ce qui est une
très bonne chose pour la démocratie je
ne pense pas que les français ont voulu
véritablement faire le choix de du
président de la république
les choses restent bien ouverts pour
notre part
et donc quelle ligne fournis il est
clairement sur une ligne progressiste
aujourd'hui on le voit à l'intérieur de
chaque partie il ya des fractures
profonde et ils ne sont plus d'accord
sur rien les partis tels qu'on les a
connus aujourd'hui ne sont pas en
capacité d'apporter des solutions
d'avenir pour le pays et c'est pour ça
que nous nous nous inscrivons dans une
démarche progressiste qui consiste à
réunir toutes les forces de progrès
toutes les composantes dont chaque
partie qui ont
jamais dire la volonté de construire un
projet commun pour pays et c'est ce qui
doit aujourd'hui être la priorité parce
que nous vivons une situation assez
assez catastrophique à tous niveaux et
les partis n'ont jusqu'ici en tout cas
pas su apporter les solutions alors
quand je voit qu'effectivement ça se
joue entre alain juppé et françois
fillon je me dis que n'ont ils pas fait
commenté pas fait donc les solutions
qu'on nous propose et que je vois sur la
table et pour l'un et pour l'autre ce
sont des solutions comptables de gestion
j'ai regardé les primaires j'avais
l'impression que c'était un concours de
premier ministrable il n'y a aucune
vision le pays a besoin de
transformation le pays a besoin d'une
profonde transformation aussi bien
institutionnels que sur ces structures
et les moyens économiques qui permettent
aux forces vraiment
de libérer l'énergie aie de libérer la
capacité de production de sport donc les
solutions effectivement nous nous
essayons d'y travailler et notre plan ce
pont de transformation sera sera bientôt
annoncée mais clairement nous invitons
tout le monde à pouvoir se réunir et
travailler dans une logique processus je
suis ravi que monsieur inscrits jean
jaurès jean luc mélenchon dans dans dans
parmi les progressistes et bien dans ce
cas là qu'il nous rejoigne et ensemble
construisons un avenir au pays
aujourd'hui la donne
je crois que on se comprend pas sur le
mot progrès 6 juste quand bon macron il
a été ministre
il a fait une politique libérale salle
ou à mâcon a permis de libéraliser
lignes de car en france on a vu ce que
ça a donné il prévoyait 22 mille
créations d'emplois il y en a eu à peine
1400 et là il y avait d'un patient qui
commence comment ça a déjà licencié il
ya 175 des sentiments en jeu donc et
qu'est ce que ça a coûté ça a coûté 250
millions d'euros à la sncf plus les 50
millions cad a dû rajouter dans le
capital de huy bus donc ça n'arrive
qu'aux autres si je suis appelé cissé a
coûté 250 millions d'euros et s'élève à
un problème structurel de gestion
qu'elle n'arrive pas à résoudre mais ça
ne sont pas à cause des carmes à combien
soin spécifique la ridt d'être qu'avant
de jeu là dessus je suis d'accord sur
les paroles structurelle de la sncf mais
pour autant il est bien clairement
établi que
250 millions de ces pertes sont dues à
cette libéralisation du dakar j'aimerais
aussi votre sentiment et peut-être aussi
une réaction pour élargir un petit peu
parce que je n'ai pas précisées alors
j'évoque est alors le fait que vous
soyez un jeune élu mais vous n'étiez pas
engager vous auparavant en positif c'est
emmanuel macron voilà c'est votre
version premier engagement qu'elle
regarde si vous portez là dessus
pourquoi vous par exemple dans des âmes
errantes macro
les propos de sendai
emmanuel macron il a eu les fonctions
d'état les plus importantes il était
secrétaire d'état il était minuté
l'économie des finances pendant deux ans
mais en tout cinq ans ils étaient
positionnés par françois hollande
maintenant il démissionne il fait sa vie
déjà on peut s'interroger sur ces
valeurs en termes de loyauté mais moi
ils maniema coup c'est un peu comme du
market une vraie c'est une étoile
filante il ya beaucoup des toits ya
beaucoup de poudre moi c'est beau il
fait beaucoup de blabla beaucoup de
meetings bon d'accord très bien qu'est
ce qui la fait
pas grand chose là et maximilien
pourtant qui est commise c'est moi
républicain on est d'accord sur ce point
là il
ya beaucoup de choses à dire vous savez
emmanuel macron et qu'elle ait eu un
mandat début non on est d'accord que
connaît-il du terrain ce qui est une
connaissance du terrain et enfin hemayma
quand il fait aussi penser
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez être
denis payre nous citoyens c'est un
mouvement voilà c'est un très grand
businessman un millionnaire très bien
très belle vie il a essayé de changer
les choses comme macron une politique
pro business comme dirait valls et à la
fin plus rien une étoile filante puis
beaucoup de lumière beaucoup de
pouvoir répondre à grand chose et ce sur
quoi je peux au moins le rejoindre c'est
que c'est une étoile il y a il y avait
un pays ami lentilles il ya très peu il
ya très peu de la lumière car il n'était
pas grave il y annonce pays très peu de
personnalités politiques qui ont su
renouveler au moins l'offre politique
est qualifié et regardons juste les
surmonter en sept mois il a réussi à
réunir plus de 100 milles à l'erreur au
moment où les partis les partis
politiques traditionnels se vident les
français
s'engage je vous invite à juste venir à
une de mes réunions et vous verrez se
tiendrait que derrière emmanuel macron
comme vous dites des milliers de
français aujourd'hui
se remette en marche il y à un mouvement
de fond qui accompagne en 1m macron
métis ou ce qui est surtout construit
est constituée dans des gens comme moi
qui venons de la société civile qui
n'avons jamais été engagée et qui depuis
le mois de mai nous sommes mis en marche
d'abord dans la grande marche où nous
avons été à la rencontre de cent mille
personnes
vingt-cinq mille questionnaires remplis
où les gens nous ont donné leur
préoccupation sur ce qui fait donc vous
allez voir une appli connaît des
problèmes des français quoi on a surtout
fait du porte à porte pour voilà écoutez
donc c'est ça que vous devez le cema
chrome se connaissent mâcon s'il était
vraiment élu il n'avait pas besoin de
poser des questions
ici nos contacts de la société civile
comme vous dites leur jamais eu besoin
de faire du porte-à-porte sont d'accord
je vais vous poser en arbitre
à la différence que à la différence que
justement depuis plus de 50 ans que vous
êtes au pouvoir n'écoutez plus les
français il fallait pas s'attendre tous
plus est mais ce que vous représentez
aujourd'hui n'ont pas été en capacité le
parti 12 hectares donc et les français
se sont juste libérés du joug de ces
partis dans les salines texte est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous disent tous
la même chose nos préoccupations ne sont
plus pris en compte par les particuliers
je vous parie sur les deux jeux sur ce
dernier point les préoccupations qui
sont pas pris en compte par les
formations politiques
traditionnelles ou plus plus ancien
parti communiste par exemple vous avez
le sentiment d'être déconnecté des
préoccupations alors je pense que non
parce que justement les communistes
vivent quand même pour une grande part
dans les quartiers populaires et
sont partie prenante de ces quartiers
populaires donc de ce point de vue là
les préoccupations des gens on les
connaît c'est d'une autre pour beaucoup
d'une part et d'autre part en effet
depuis depuis très longtemps les parties
qu'on appelle les partis du gouvernement
n'ont pas pris en compte ces
préoccupations et au contraire ont
contribué à
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
paupérisation de la société on va
revenir sur deux sujets à présent pour
avancer un peu et sortir de la politique
et des hommes politiques sur deux sujets
de société tout d'abord la nouvelle
campagne des restos du coeur qui vient
de débuter 32e campagne des restos du
coeur depuis le 22 novembre
l'association qui va distribuer à
plusieurs centaines de milliers de repas
le nombre de bénéficiaires augmente
sylvia les travailleurs pauvres il ya
les retraités aussi et là concrètement
on a trois visions différentes trois
formations politiques différentes
quelles sont vos propositions et votre
regard pour aider justement ces
différentes couches de la population
moi ce que je constate c'est juste que
on est en train de structurer alizés
les moyens
pour aider là c'est sûr que les restos
du coeur avait une vocation à
disparaître rapidement à ces seules en
guise longue luche et aujourd'hui on
voit que ce n'est pas le cas exact on ne
savait plus de 2 milliards et des
milliards de revoir à dire une deuxième
campagne 32e campagne de trop aux
loisirs et 2 milliards de repas
distribués
et 110 dont claude sur l'échec criant de
ces politiques alternatives qui nous ont
conduit à cette situation et je vois
qu'aujourd'hui encore au lieu de
s'attaquer aux causes on structure les
conséquences c'est à dire on est en
train d'organiser par des nouvelles
langues notamment les moyens de
pérenniser le financement des restos du
coeur ça veut dire qu'on accepte que la
pauvreté s'installe de façon
structurelle dans le pays c'est
inacceptable donc aujourd'hui nous vous
proposions une transformation de fond
qui re donne du travail aux gens
actuellement nous faisons dans le cadre
d' en marche une marche des quartiers où
nous sommes sur le terrain à la
recherche et au contact des populations
dans les quartiers difficiles d'euros
contre des gens vous ont déroulé at il
est incroyable puisque rôle les
intervenants qui sont là mais sur cette
question là de faire intervenir
les quartiers de parler de cette
jeunesse des quartiers des talents qui
sont cachés on entend que l'on entend
parler à chacune des campagnes
électorales en fait et on entend parler
de uniquement pendant ces périodes là eh
bien nous nous allons brûler nous avons
aujourd'hui mettre sur la table cet
enjeu on a voulu nous enfermer dans le
débat sur la laïcité ce n'était pas les
préoccupations il ya quelques semaines
du débat public nous n'avons pu le
remettre au centre du débat c'est à dire
travailler pour les reconstituer nos
concitoyens faire en sorte que ceux qui
investissent ceux qui prennent des
risques puisse être véritablement au
coeur de nos préoccupations
heureusement nicolas sarkozy n'est plus
là donc le débat pourra être un peu plus
sur le programme un peu plus sur les
propositions et surtout ciblé pour
remettre le pays en marche vous faire
réagir tous les deux est juste un mot
sans revenir sur la primaire on entend
quand même malgré tout beaucoup parlé
pendant cette campagne du 1er 2e tour de
rigueur il faut supprimer des postes de
fonctionnaires et on va alors qu'on
parle d'une réalité difficile
aujourd'hui comment comment aider ces
populations pauvres tout en même temps
on disant qu'il faut augmenter la tva
qu'il faut plus de moins de
fonctionnaires gagnaient tout à fait
d'accord qui a donné de nouveau statut d
auto-entrepreneur en 2009 pour faciliter
justement l'accès en entrepreneuriat
sarkozy ça c'est une vulgaire
structurelles sur les musulmanes par les
végétaux pas non mais il faut pas je
pense qu'on fonde des politiques
économiques et les politiques
budgétaires les politiques budgétaires
doivent accompagner l'économie
congé c'est françois hollande quand en
2013 on a créé le choc fiscal le plus
important après la seconde guerre
mondiale là je sais des propos de
christophe saint-etienne qui est prix
nobel d'économie est ce que vous aviez
en douter que nous sera grand et que
monsieur macron pardonnez moi qui était
secrétaire d'état je crois à cette
époque avait soutenu après ça on met en
demandant fin on impose des lois aux
français le 49 3 il était aux marrons
troisième point pour aider l'économie il
faut former et donner l'accès à
l'apprentissage par le savoir est une
arme les républicains l'ont très vite
compris nicolas sarkozy était le premier
à avoir donné la possibilité par exemple
aux alternants de toucher la bourse en
même temps ça mais vous ne proposez rien
avec nous sommes les seuls à proposer
la compagnie met vite par exemple nous
proposons la nationalisation de l'unedic
et franchement avec ce que je veux dire
à roger milla
déterminer si vous lisez mal mais le bio
nomique il faut faire des mesures qui
sont importantes pour protéger les
futures générations je suis d'accord
c'est un pas plaire à tout le monde mais
abandonnée par exemple sur les régimes
de retraite françois hollande s'était
premier avoir avoir dit non la retraite
c'est 60 ans quelques années plus près
les même pas un an plus tard il dit
c'est 62 après 10 63 ça va jusqu'où
macron c'est pas mieux donc à moi de
juger la droite à des pommiers non plus
parce que le terrain soit 65 65
l'édifice avait besoin voilà assez
chacun voilà médias savoir mais ce que
je vais dire pour terminer c'est que si
on veut vraiment aider les jeunes et les
chômeurs parce qu'il ya quand même six
mois aux chômeurs dans le pays c'est la
formation d'apprentissage donné cet
axe-là donner plus de compétences
notamment aux régions qui est parce que
là le monopole l'avc le pôle emploi qui
a le monopole de la formation
individuelle il je pense qu'ils seraient
par exemple quelque chose de très
technique puisqu'on parle de terrain on
parle d'élus locaux là et bien lorsque
pas dans les régions s'ils ont la
possibilité d'obtenir la formation
individuelle je pense que ça pourrait
créer de la synergie
d'action énorme dans votre discours vous
vous dites il faut donner les moyens aux
collectivités territoriales pour
développer par exemple la formation mais
vos candidats et vos candidats prévoit 2
baisser drastiquement les moyens de
l'état avec des avec des 100 milliards
et les 90 pas la qualité si on peut
travailler avec la critique quand il ya
des bruits de fond
le terminer ça serait pas mal donc je
débute par le monde de plus
fonctionnaires d'autre part le budget on
est prêt juppé comme
fillon
prévoit 90 à 100 milliards d'économies
sur le budget de fonctionnement de
l'état comment ça se passe c'est
forcément d'avoir bien sûr des postes de
fonctionnaires mais c'est aussi des
moyens consacrés à l'éducation des
moyens consacrés
à l'enseignement dès l'apprentissage et
c est moi je pense que là de ce point de
vue là plutôt que de réduire les moyens
de l'état il faut en donner plus et
notamment en allant chercher les niches
fiscales les fraudes fiscales
on a les 50 à 100 milliards
tous les ans qui disparaissent et ses 50
à 100 milliards si on les avait en
caisses de l'état ça permettrait
rapidement d'oublier la dette dont on se
fait beaucoup mourront à ce sujet ça
permettrait d'investir en effet dans
l'éducation c'est un point essentiel
aujourd'hui dans l'est dans les
quartiers il y a des comment dire des
écoles où ils manquent de mettre deux
maîtresses d'enseignants dans le
secondaire d'enseignants au lycée c'est
inadmissible que l'on laisse des jeunes
sans
enseignement pendant des fois plusieurs
mois et ça que ce soit
dans les quartiers populaires ou
ailleurs peu importe il est
indispensable de relancer l'attrait de
l'enseignement pour les jeunes
générations aujourd'hui quand il ya
l'éducation qui bassin qui lance un
concours d'enseignant il ya % poste il
ya quarante candidats c'est inadmissible
il faudrait que j'en aime il est que ces
gens là à terme soient assurés d'avoir
un poste
correctement payés et comment dire où
ils soient sûrs de leur l'intérêt de
leur travail
est pourquoi pour conclure alors on
demande alors de nous va bien on met le
au centre du débat les problèmes de
formation sauf que qui propose qu
aujourd'hui de changer de système en
marche
compris sur juste une mesure qui est
très importante et la nationalisation
bénédicte vous avez évoqué quelque chose
qui va permettre qui va permettre de
d'utiliser les milliards qui sont
aujourd'hui
octroyés aux travailleurs de pouvoir
l'utiliser pour les chômeurs les gens
sans emploi je vous un terroir êtes-vous
soirée et donc vos employés ces points
sont révolus ces redditions je vous
interromps là ne serait ce que parce
qu'une fois de plus le format de
l'émission étant trop court il ya
beaucoup de sujets qu'on n'aura pas le
temps d'aborder malheureusement juste
pour conclure juste luxe que vous vous
retenez de l'actualité à chacun on va
faire un tour de table pour les
dernières minutes dernières minutes
d'émission qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
dans l'actualité dans la presse de ces
10 15 derniers jours ce qui m'a marqué
moi personnellement c'est les primaires
à droite puisque on est en plein dedans
c'est pour moi il un exemple de
démocratie à la base n'était pas pour
mais à la fin on trouve c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on parlait d'une
participation en baisse on voit la
participation massive donc on a montré
que la droite pouvait réunir et même si
c'est messenger n'est pas d'accord sur
des résultats pour les avaient plus de
chances d'élection présidentielle je
pense que ça a été une bonne chose
c'était une bonne leçon de démocratie
pour notre pays c'était quelque chose de
très fort 4 millions de français ont
voté
peut-être pour le futur président de la
république donc voilà je t'aime précisé
et avant toute chose je retiens aussi
peut-être le jeu de 1024 qu'on n'a pas
eu le temps d'aborder qu'on devait
aborder et qu'on n'a pas abordé
effectivement puisque la france vient de
présenter la candidature à doha c'était
le premier grand oral et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sa copine son
fonctionnement très impactées envie
d'être en victoire voilà vous donnera
l'occasion de reparler d'ici là moi je
un sujet qu'on n'a pas abordé et qui
pourtant à mon avis nous concerne tous
c'est la clôture de la coop 22e
au maroc
là on a comment dire un sujet qui est
transnational il en va de la survie de
l'espèce humaine c'est pas de la planète
dont on parle hein c'est de l'espèce
humaine donc et je pense que
cette conférence où une coopération
internationale se met en place avec des
hauts et des bas bien sûr ça devrait
être un exemple un exemple pour aussi
nos débats nationaux locaux à tous
points de vue il est essentiellement
d'ailleurs économique la coopération est
bien meilleure que la compétitivité pour
faire avancer les choses et je pense que
dans le domaine de comment dire
du développement durable c'est un fait
essentiel mais c'est aussi l'essentiel
en économie mais c'est vrai que cette
scop on en a assez peu parlé dans les
médias au niveau national alors que
l'élection du nouveau président
américain plutôt plutôt opposés à ces
différentes propositions trop de
l'environnement aurait pu faire
l'actualité vous avez bien fait de le
souligner ce que vous retenez et ne me
dites pas que c'est l'entrée en campagne
officielle des manuels macro il ya bien
plus important que ça moi ce qui m'a
retenu c'est ce qui a retenu mon
attention c'est surtout là
le problème des migrants de problème les
migrants et surtout des réfugiés ou dans
le département on a vu des réactions ici
et là qui n'était pas du tout à la
hauteur du de ce drame nous nions pas
que les réfugiés sont pour beaucoup des
gens qui fuient la misère qui fait
surtout la guerre et que je pense que
notre région s'honorerait de les
accueillir dignement et surtout d'avoir
une stratégie une politique adaptée a
assez à ces personnes qui pour beaucoup
ont
j'avais bien
un cursus des diplômés un niveau qui
pourrait leur permettre de se réintégrer
très facilement
paysager dans le pays et on n'a pas
encore une vision claire et une
politique une stratégie qui soit
efficace pour pouvoir les accompagner
les accueillir dignement et leur
permettent pour beaucoup de reprendre
une activité ou une formation qui les
conduirait à mieux s'intégrer dans la
société française et j'ai vu ici et là
des manifestations même contre l'arrivée
de ces réfugiés qui sont quand même
pas de nature à honorer notre retard à
cause du kent
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à sept cafés politiques prochaine
édition prochain numéro ce sera le 10
décembre toujours sur téléfilm merci de
nous avoir suivis
[Musique]